That Vox WILL register
1 bill that aims to
reduce personal income tax for all Spaniards.
Our initiative will focus on modifying
the state section,
establishing 1 single rate of 1 15% for those who win
less than €70,000 per year
and 1 25% for those who exceed this amount.
Income below €22,000 would be exempt.
In addition,
in our initiative we contemplate
reduce 4 percentage points
for each child.
In other words,
1 family that has 4 children would not pay personal income tax.
if the rent is less than €70,000 and would pay
only 1 9 per 100
if their income exceeds 70,000.
We know that this reduction in personal income tax is going to mean
in turn 1 fall
in the collection of the state-owned portion of the
from 1 30% to up to 1 45%.
I mean,
as the left says,
that healthcare is GOING to get worse,
that there will be no education,
that there will be no roads.
Let's look at the numbers,
the corresponding income tax collection
to the state section
scheduled for 2 023
is approximately 41 billion.
The impact of our income tax reduction measure
will be between 12 and 18 billion euros.
Do you know how much money the government spent on subsidies?
direct during the year?
2 022
29 billion.
There is no lack of money.
Leftover
ways to waste the money of all Spaniards